hello everyone and welcome to what could
be the most awaited game of the World
rapid championship this is round four
even we have a clash between two world
champions Magnus Carlsen the world
classical Champion versus Notre Bak last
year as a world rapid Champion uh if you
haven't seen their game last year in the
world rapid Championship where another
big had the white pieces and Magnus had
black uh I I I really suggest you check
that out before watching this video it
will be the first link in the
description below it's a beautiful game
and you will appreciate this one much
more if you haven't seen that one so now
uh as Magnus has lost that game he wants
uh Revenge will he be able to do it and
what will he employ will it be another
B3 or will he play some normal stuff uh
let's check it out so Magnus has the
white pieces and he challenges noderbeck
with another Pawn to B3 he goes for
another nimso Larson attack E5 by
another by going for uh control of the
center of very standard stuff but should
be two knights to the C6 and now Pawn to
E3 we have Knight to F7 and not Knight
to F3 Magnus trying to get um another
back to advance the Ponte E4 which is
usually the case you either defend or
Advance uh to E4 but he goes for Bishop
to D6 it's it's an extremely rare move
and only been played a handful of times
so does Magnus have something prepared
for this uh he continues with some
standard move spawn to C4 we have
castles and now there is a game where
Knight the C3 was played but Magnus
plays Pawn to D3 and it is now as of
move 6 that we have a completely new
game uh more than we could ask for in a
game between these two world champions
uh Rook to E8 uh we have A3 and now A5
stopping B4 with Bishop to E2 by Magnus
preparing the castle and the bishop now
retreats to f8 where another bag is
preparing to strike in the center with
D5 we have castles and the immediate
Pawn to D5 we have characters captors
and now Knight B to D2 F6 and here Queen
to C2 you can see how magnus's spawns
are are set up on the a third of the
rank like this which really prevents
Those Nights from going anywhere and the
queen is very safe on C2 Bishop to F5
now putting pressure on that diagonal
and Rook after E1 uh we uh it seems like
you could go uh sorry E4 here but you
can't if you go upon T4 then Knight the
F4 puts pressure on the bishop the
bishop is undefended this would come
with checks so that's why Magnus just
defends the bishop and now it he
definitely is threatening Pawn to E4
Bishop back to G6 and now uh we have the
move that completely jump starts the
game and that is Pawn to G4 now there
were discussions of maybe the maybe
Magnus is playing planning this or maybe
not whether he's gonna play King to H1
first then Rook to G1 then G4 maybe he
will prepare it with H3 and then and
maybe uh some sort of a G4 later on but
no he goes for the immediate G4 and move
14 and this is now now we have a fight
so Queen to D7 another big challenges
the pawn and now King to H1 Magnum shows
that the pawn cannot be captured if you
capture the pawn and then look at this
Knight captures on E5 and the black
pretty much resigns Knight F5 Knight
captures on G6 Queen captures and
whatever Knight F3 now the Rooks will
double up on the G file and that's
pretty much it so after King to H1 just
Rook a to d8 another back continues to
put pressure on the default the D3 Pawn
is very weak and now we have Knight to
E4 uh we have King to h8 uh very very
useful move uh and and okay G5 is coming
at some in some lines maybe even Knight
captures an F6 so you don't want that to
come with check so a useful move and now
Rook 8 to D1 and this is a really a
precise move by Magnus it's not even the
engine's First Choice
um but the engine's First Choice Rook to
G1 uh would allow Northern back to go
for this knight uh Dita B for idea for a
night sacrifice in order to win uh some
pawns and take control over the game if
he captures Knight captures attacks the
queen and the D3 pawn and after the
queen moves you will capture an D3
attack everything here and now you have
to trade otherwise maybe just Bishop
captures Knight captures on F2 with
check if the queen just moves so here
you will have to trade Queen captures
and for the for your piece you've won
two pawns and you uh you've completely
shattered White's position so Magnus to
avoid the displays Rook 8 D1 adds
another Defender to the D3 pawn and now
Bishop to F7 here another back wants to
move the Knight and he wants to put
pressure on that B3 pawn and challenge
it with a move like Pawn to A4 so Rook
the G1 Magnus is now ready to start
lifting those Rooks we have Knight the
B6 and now Rook to G3 you could also
consider the immediate G5 Magnus prefers
to double up first A4 and out you you
don't have the luxury of B4 because then
just Bishop to B3 and you you can resign
so B captures an A4 wins the pawn but uh
magnus's uh Queen side is now completely
shattered and if another back is able to
regain material which you most probably
will uh he will have Advantage here on
the queen side
so Knights the A5 now he frees up the uh
Queen's attack to the A4 pawn and Rook D
to G1 Magnus doubles up on the G file
and now you should play Knight captures
on A4 as this puts immediate pressure on
the bishop and B2 and you will just have
a very nice game however uh Bishop to D5
is what Northern back plays and this
allows Magnus to uh sort of uh will get
a better
grip of the attack because now uh he can
play Pawn to G5 and now look at this
Ponte F5 and this is where the fun
really starts uh I mean it doesn't uh
just start here like uh here Magnus goes
back to C3 but he could have played
Knight to F6 an incredible move that
just uh completely destroys another king
side the problem is after G captures uh
Pawn captures uh look at this you have
the bishop you have the Rooks doubled on
the G file there's still no clear way
why this is so good but it would be
incredibly different difficult to defend
for example you offer a queen trade
white would decline you're going to play
Bishop to H6 now comes E4 and look at
this what do you what do you even play
here if F captures an E4 then you're
just gonna play F7 you're gonna attack
the rook and if uh if the bishop moves
or if anything just for example Bishop
captures Knight captures and E5 opens up
this diagonal and you resign here uh so
Knight to F6 was very very tricky but
impossible to calculate very quickly so
Magnus goes back Knight to the C3 and
now we have Bishop to C6 uh Magnus
strikes in the center with e for now and
now Knight captures an A4 another back
not being fooled by any uh Center uh
Pawn pushes Knight captures an A4 Bishop
captures and A4 and now Queen to C3
doubling up on this diagonal and here we
have Knight to C6 and now Pawn to G6 and
how can how can another bag defend this
the problem is uh it's incredibly
difficult if you play H6 here which you
kinda don't want to do but it does seem
to you know stop White's attack the
problem is Knight to G5 and what do you
play here Knight F7 check is now coming
and if you capture this Rook H3 check
and if King to jail captures on G5 and
well you are coming for for the blacking
very quickly there are even some nasty
tricks here like let's say rookie 6 D4
and now whatever you play let's say he
captures on D4 Rook to h8 checking
captures Queen to H3 check king j8 and
queen to H7 checkmate
so this is all possible if uh noderbeck
plays H6 so he doesn't he says I'm not
falling for that he plays Knight to D4
threatening uh this beautiful uh triple
Fork uh Knight captures and he would
Fork the Queen the rook and the other
Rook uh and here Magnus has a beautiful
move that if he finds he will have great
winning chances so feel free to pause
the video and find the winning idea for
Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on sacrificing
everything and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Knight to
G5 this is what Magnus played and now
it's a very very hard to figure out how
to go about this position uh it seems
that you really should be able to take
the bishop but you really can't the only
way to defend this is to play Rook to E7
to add another Defender to the to the F7
square but this is such an uh such an
ugly move such a difficult move to even
consider that after considering uh
Northern big just played Knight captures
on E2 now he attacks the queen The Rook
ended the rook and uh to make matters
even more interesting Magnus misses the
winning line Magnus plays Knight the F7
check and he trades down into a in into
a better end game but the real winner
was Queen to C4 adding uh more pressure
to the F7 square and now you really have
nothing even if you pick up the other
Rook with check Rook captures there's no
move you can play here if you play let's
say Bishop B5 you play something the
real problem is Knight to F7 check and
after King to Jade Knight to H6 a double
check and now after king th8 queen to G8
Checkmate you don't even need the final
Knight F7 Checkmate uh as you usually
get in the uh in the in the smarter
mates because okay here the queen is
covering F7 and also you don't have Rook
captures and G8 but you don't need it
Queen to G8 is Checkmate and also uh
even if afterward characters on G3 you
don't play something like this you play
rookie seven which kind of stops that g
captures an H7 and there's no stopping
Checkmate look at this that Bishop is
just so bad but Magnus misses this and
he goes for Knight to F7 with check and
not Northern back happily trades down as
that's the only thing uh left for him we
have Queen captures G captures an F7 now
Knight captures on C3 he has to
recapture the queen and now F captures
an E8 bringing you a queen into the game
Bishop capture 78 and now Bishop
captures and C3 and here Bishop to G6
here with F4 uh it's it's still very
interesting but after Bishop to G6
Magnus just opens up the G file for
himself he captures Bishop captures and
now Bishop captures on E5 and another
back is in a really really bad spot here
uh that uh the G7 Pawn is being attacked
and for example Rook 37 Rook F3 very
very annoying you have to find some very
very precise moves here like like Rook
to F7 and then Rook G to G3 the game
just continues but Magnus is just so
much better here the problem is another
back thought that this was never a
threat and he just plays Bishop captures
on D3 now he's up a pawn and it seems
that uh you know things are looking good
for him the problem is Magnus doesn't
play the move that Notre back thought he
would play he doesn't play Bishop
captures on G7 because this would just
lose look at this bishop captures and G7
Rook captures and it seems like you're
up the exchange but there's Bishop e for
check and now if you play Rook one to a
G2 then Rook to D1 is Checkmate and if
you bring this Rook here then Rook G8
and you've completely tied down magnus's
pieces and you will just uh you know win
this end game without much problems
however after Bishop captures on the
three Magnus surprise noted back and he
didn't play Bishop captures in G7
instead he played Rook captures and G7
and he was in this position unmoved 35
that uh Northern back abdusato resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here now the problem is it
doesn't matter what you play if you
start with Bishop to E4 check uh just
Rook 7 to G2 blocks check and delivers a
discovery check and the King has no
squares even though the Rook is pinned
The Rook can still prevent the king from
going to G8 and now you have to give up
the bishop and after Bishop captures The
Rook has to go under the mask here and
now again Bishop to F6 check will pick
up this Rook as well later Bishop
captures real captures with checking F7
Bishop capture 78 Magnus is just up too
much material and even if you don't go
for this if afterward captures on G7 you
just pick up the Rook it doesn't really
matter Bishop captures now Kings to G8
Bishop to F6 check and again pretty much
same thing King tier 7 Bishop captures
okay you will have to give up The Rook
here captures characters captures but
you are up a full piece and of course
completely winning so it's not uh it was
not as intense as the game last year
last year's game was just I mean you
could
you couldn't uh watch it and be still it
was so so intense like if you haven't
seen it do check it out first link in
the description below uh but yeah here
magnus's manages to put Magnus manages
to pull out a win with the B3 and him so
Larson and uh well what what a game it
was really really incredible stuff and
even though Magnus missed uh here after
Knight to D4 uh he found Knight the G5
but then after Knight captures I need to
he didn't find Queen to see for Queen to
C4 is just the one that you know goes
into every book and it's uh it would be
winning in the style of Old Masters but
in the end okay it it worked out for him
and he takes the the lead he is now on
four out of four and we'll see who who
who will face him next uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
beautiful Clash of two world champions
uh the the classical and the rapid world
champion and now Magnus by defeating the
last year's World rapid Champion uh
shows that he is very very serious about
winning the world rapid championship for
himself so I once again hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Ricky
black Lars Oliver grundhaba Jeff Graves
dick rice Oxley and David Kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day